this week the media blew up over
president Trump's allegations last
Friday night at a rally that there had
been some sort of terrible event in
Sweden he said quote last night they
suggested that Trump had mentioned a
phantom terror attack in the same way
Kellyanne Conway mentioned the Bowling
Green massacre and Sean Spicer reference
to terror attack in Atlanta that never
happened here's a trump actually said in
his speech we got to keep our country
safe you look at what's happening
interment you look at what's happening
last night in Sweden Sweden who would
believe this Sweden they took in large
numbers they're having problems they
never thought possible this is a near
perfect example of how Trumpy and
rhetoric polarizes the electorate why
because Trump was wrong to say something
had happened in Sweden last night
nothing had happened that night but he
was absolutely right to point out
increased crime problems among Muslim
immigrants to Sweden conservatives
reacted Trump's comments by pretending
that Trump had never used the phrase
last night leftist pretended nothing
terrible had ever happened in Swede
never ever ever then last night actually
last night news broke of a Muslim
immigrant rally this is from the local
newspaper Sweden's capital was plunged
into chaos on Mondays police were forced
to fire at rioters after violence
erupted in an area described as
high-risk the terrifying scenes took
place just hours after the country's
Prime Minister Stefan Roth ivenn slams
Donald Trump for claiming Sweden was in
crisis as a result of its liberal
refugee policy style employees were
forced to fire a shot into the rampaging
crowd in the hard-hit suburb of rink be
after a mob of around 30 thugs started
attacking the officers with rocks
violence erupted after the police had
tried to arrest a wanted person on the
subway here's the thing Sweden does have
a serious problem with rising rates of
rape correlating with increased
immigration from Muslim countries as
Joker love daily wire points i'll quote
there were sixty six point five cases of
reported rapes per 100,000 inhabitants
last year that's triple right up from
24.9 in 2003 so one heck of a jump even
ABC News was forced to acknowledge the
Trump wasn't entirely wrong is from ABC
News last year 112,000 645 violent
crimes were reported in Sweden an
increase from 108,000 739 and 2015
108,000 71 and 2014 and 104,000 738 in
2013 according to the swedish national
council for crime prevention those
numbers include attempted murder
muggings and rape
other types of sexual assault and
Mercury Council said and this is from
one of the mayor's one of the tenants of
the police reports don't have a box you
tick about whether it's a Swedish
citizen or an immigrant the council
looks instead in a number of factors
according to ABC News the council's hit
a number of social factors including
income and education but not immigration
status or ethnicity Trump rightly
tweeted give the public a break the fake
news media is trying to say that
large-scale immigration and Sweden is
working out just beautifully not all
caps photo editors like we're in 1993
Malmo Sweden has turned into a hospital
for anti-semitism thanks to rising
Muslim immigration here's fox news on
the rising problem of violence in Malmo
last month the police chief for the
southern Swedish study of Malmo issued a
desperate plea for help curtailing a
plague of attempted murders beatings and
rapes about thirty two percent of Mount
Mo's occupants are migrants although it
is not clear what role migrants play in
the crime wave we cannot do it on our
own she's Stefan sentius wrote in an
open letter about the upward spiral of
violence Malmo had 52 hand grenade
attacks in 2016 alone a jump from 48
attacks in 2015 according to figures
provided by the Swedish police authority
you want to know why conservatives don't
trust the media it's because of media
over each suggesting that when
conservatives get a specific wrong but
the general right the general is also
wrong that's not an excuse for Trump to
make silly mistakes he's the president
but it does demonstrate why
conservatives are willing to give him
the benefit of the doubt so long he's
talking about real problems the left
refuses to contemplate I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay tons to get to on today's show as
always we're going to get to the
emotionality of left why they seem to be
over emotional about this election we're
going to talk about the ongoing war
between Trump and the media and whereas
having a special guest later in the
program as well as deconstructing the
culture but first we have to say thank
you so our advertisers over at bowlin
branch so bow and branch is one of these
advertisers but I've actually spent my
own money on their product they sent me
a free set of sheets and i love the
sheets so much that i went and I bought
a second set of sheets on my own dime
because they make the bet streets i'm a
very light sleeper i don't sleep well
bull and branch sheets make me sleep
better and the reason they make me sleep
better is they are breathable they are
their life they are their area like you
know you don't know what it's like to
sleep in the night set of sheets until
you've actually done it you think to
yourself okay what's the difference
between the ten-dollar set of sheets
that you get at the at the local gas
station and a five-hundred-dollar set of
sheets or a thousand-dollar sentries the
reality is it makes a huge difference it
can absolutely affect the quality of
your sleep I can vouch for that it has
made my sleep a lot better which is
important to me since my children don't
let me sleep so the five minutes when I
sleep better be good so Bolin branch is
the place that you go for all of this
you go to bolt and branch calm today get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets
don't worry the sheets are not only
affordable they're much more affordable
than luxury sheets elsewhere it's bull
and branch combi oll and branch calm
promo code been make sure you use the
promo code been so they know that we
sent you and also because they are
because you will then get that fifty
dollar discounts off your first set of
sheets totally worth it you're going to
love it I promise okay so I want to talk
today about the absolute mental
breakdown that is apparently happening
among some folks on left because of
Donald Trump's election and I don't mean
this figuratively I mean this literally
this is an article from CNN okay while
we think stun has always been a news
junkie but since president Trump was
elected he's been so anxious about the
political tunneled that even just having
the TV on in the background at home is
unbearable it's been crippling said the
35 year old San Mateo California
resident and political moderate who has
supported both Democrats and Republicans
in the past I feel angry really really
angry far more angry than I expected to
be he's tried hard to determine he's
tried hard to quell his anxiety first he
shut down his facebook page to limit his
exposure to the daily soaking of news
from Washington but not knowing the
glowing time into nervous too he found
himself sneaking onto facebook the
account he made for his dog oh yes this
is a fellow who made a facebook account
for his dog I felt like I was cheating
he said Kingston is not alone in his
politics induced anxiety it's so common
it's been given an unofficial name
post-election stress disorder mental
health professionals around the country
especially those working in democratic
strongholds report a stream of patients
coming in with anxiety and depression
related to or worsened by the blast of
daily news on the new administration
well I can actually personally voucher
this my wife who's a doctor says that
they've been having an influx of people
who are coming in with stress induced
anxiety because of the election there
are psychiatrists who are reporting all
around the state of California that
they've seen their roles just dominate
they've been going up and up they've
never had the book patients like this
because people are so upset about the
election CNN you know says in the past
therapists say it's been fairly uncommon
for patients to bring up politics on the
couch it's big money to talk about
politics with me that's not what we do
said Maria lim Burris a psychiatrist in
santa monica california so the question
becomes why is it that the left has lost
its mind about this particularly
remember there was bushed arrangement
syndrome they really hated george w bush
they couldn't deal with the fact he was
president but this is onion it's another
level howard dean is the former head of
the Democratic National Committee here's
what he had to say about people being
traumatized by the election now is the
intensity of the Hillary favorables
becoming more intense but it's not
changing the overall I don't hear her
name lately only when Trump brings about
AI really not good she'll come back
right now she has a hundred percent
right but I'm betting what's happened is
these young people have been traumatized
by Trump's election because it was
essentially a reneging on every single
value that somebody in this country
under 35 has they were shocked okay so
everybody is traumatized by the election
James Franco right the the overrated
actor he said that he has what he said
he said I mean I've been reacting really
badly I spiraled into a depression I've
been questioning everything that I am I
wish I had questioned everything that he
was before he was the Green Goblin in
spider-man cuz i was quite awful so the
okay so everybody is losing their mind /
/ trumps elections and now we have to
discuss why that is so there's no
question that Donald Trump is a
stressful human okay Donald Trump is a
stressful
when he induces stretch in his opponents
in his friend in his family you can see
like everybody around Trump is stressed
all the time Trump's the only person who
seems pretty saying what about being
Trump like it's kind of amusing actually
Donald Trump looks very happy to be him
but everyone around him looks like
they're like they're fighting through a
pencil like if they had a pencil there'd
be teeth marks all over the pencil
that's true okay he says things that are
wild and crazy he does things that are
weird all of that's true but that's not
the real reason why people are stressed
is not the real reason why people aren't
anxious because it turns out that we've
had a bunch of weirdos in the White
House before that Bill Clinton was no
picnic I think Trump's another level the
bill clinton was no picnic LBJ was no
picnic we've had a bunch of weird
presidents before people who are weirdos
and cooked in the 19th century there's a
whole series of weirdos and cooks right
in a row before the Civil War so you
know there's this idea that the
president is always some sort of beacon
of calm and indecency in in the country
is just not true it's just not real so
what's the real reason why this is it's
because the media ratchet everything up
the media ratchet everything up so
here's the thing two things can be true
at once things can be very chaotic and
Trump land and also that chaos can
manifest in very small ways that don't
actually matter the most people with
lives here's my question how does it
matter to your life left to right how
does it matter to your right your life
that Trump is president has your life
changed in any market why we didn't
really change all that much under Obama
like I hated Obama as a president I hope
he's a terrible president I thought it
was really bad for the country you know
and that made me anxious it made me
upset didn't make me like go see a
psychiatrist no of course not because
that's silly but you know that but did
he change my life in any serious
material way I don't think so I really
don't think so and I don't think that
and I think that's true for most
Americans like if you're if you're a
barren elf specimen living in Washington
state and local government is shutting
you down because you're religious
business owner then you can say the
government is really affecting your life
in tremendously horrible ways but the
truth is most of what happens in
Washington DC does not have direct
impact on you yes there there are times
when it impacts you but it have a few
and far between i think for the vast
majority of americans so why is
everybody really going nuts it's because
everybody's into the news and we watch
the news as entertainment and the
entertainment news has decided that
everything in the world is about to
collapse we are on the edge of collapse
we're sitting right there on
class and one little push by Trump and
the entire country is going to be like
wile e coyote we're gonna look down
we're going to be in midair we're going
to look down realize we're in midair and
then it's going to and you see the cloud
of smoke puffs up from the ground right
that's that sort of how the media is
portraying all of this and the media's
bias on this is really making people
kind of not so here's an example of some
of the media's bias this is an amazing a
headline from NBC News yesterday and
beasts it is three this is the NBC news
yesterday has this headline there's a
real headline president Trump reaches 32
days won't be shortest US president
first of all James Madison was the
shortest US president of 54 but second
of all says he reaches 32 days and he
won't be the shortest US president the
implicit expectation of this headline is
that we are so crazy here that we have
to get Trump out if you're like right
now in the first 30 days and we should
just be grateful the world hasn't ended
in the first 30 days of his
administration I think number one
everybody is under estimating the
durability of the constitutional system
there are lots of checks and balances it
turns out it's actually hard to push
your agenda it turns out that Barack
Obama couldn't do all the things that he
wanted to do because there were checks
and balances in the system Trump is
discovering those same checks and
balances inside the system he really
hasn't done anything that major yet he
hasn't right or left I understand the
right one wants to be over the moon
about Trump okay fine I understand the
left wants to be crazy about Trump
that's a little less fine here's the
reality Trump hasn't done anything very
big yet ready at the Mexico City
polities done a lot of little things
that I think are good he's nominated
Gorsuch which i think is a big good
thing that's pretty much it have you
seen a big piece of policy come out of
the Trump administration not yet and so
wouldn't it behoove us to wait and see
house talking to Andrew Clavin about
this yesterday his Clavin is over the
moon about Trump and what I was saying
to him is it's a little too early to
make hard and fast judgments about
whether to be over the moon about Trump
you're you're at a museum right now and
you're standing right up close to a
Seurat painting okay before people don't
know cerati is a pointless painter you
know Sunday in the park with George
which just made this more obscure day if
you're standing in front of a Seurat
painting okay it's a bunch of dots right
it's all you see from right in front of
it a bunch about them and as you pull
out you see that it's this amazing
picture of Sunday in the park with
George right but if you if you are too
close to it it just looks like a bunch
of dots we're only 30 days in right now
Trump's administration is a bunch of
dots it's a little too early to say that
when you pull out from the picture it's
going to be a picture of nuclear armed
or that it can be a picture of utopia we
just don't know yet but the media are
portraying it is Armageddon or they're
saying we're right on the verge of
Armageddon unless you're worried unless
you're worried quick rule about worrying
folks worrying has never done anybody
any good concern that drives you to
action is one thing worry fretting
nobody's ever had a better life because
they worried more okay worry does not
make your life any better but this is
what the media are pushing this idea
that we're in the middle of this giant
crisis all the time NBC released a
series of propaganda videos starring
children who are worried worried about
Donald Trump these these kids I mean
this is indoctrination here here mr.
president dear mr. president young mr.
president
I'm excited for a political outsider
that can solve a disconnect between the
American citizens and the legislators
are Washington when you speak on things
that make me feel uncomfortable or I
disagree with you make me feel small
because I know I can't change it I want
you to know that I don't like your
definition of American because I don't
seem to fit within it most of my family
is black I'm afraid that you're going to
hurt someone bus black right now you're
just kinda in the middle we're swaying
towards bad but I think you can choose
active you are here attempting to
whitewash America yeah I don't know
separate me away from my family and I
really know what that probably a no
music okay I hate I hate in politics
when people use children as a sort of
proxy for what they want to say
themselves i hate when you use children
as tools unlike some other folks I hate
when you use children as Jules I think
that it's just terrible and so you know
when you when you look at this kind of
video and the media is using these kids
as propaganda vehicles what do you
expect people to feel like does this
make you feel not anxious makes me feel
more anxious to make you feel anxious it
makes you feel like this poor kid right
she's gonna be walking around homeless
on the streets of Los Angeles because
Donald Trump personally wasn't kicked in
the door and dragged away her screaming
mother right how's that supposed to not
make you feel nervous and then you
wonder why the anxiety is up that's not
good by the way when the country's
anxiety is up like we on the right we
can laugh at have the snowflakes ahaha
okay first of all the easiest thing in
the world is melting snow flakes I do it
for a living it's very easy it's not
hard but beyond that it's not good when
the entire country feels like it is a
series of snowflakes that are melting
because eventually when you have a bunch
of people who are in constant crisis
anxiety panic mode something busts loose
and I think that we're entering the
verge of that in the media is really
propagating that in a major way well
speaking of sort of the crisis that
could happen this is why folks this is
why you always have to be prepared for
crisis so whether they're optimistic or
pessimistic about the future of the
country whether you feel like we're on
the right track or a wrong track as what
we just saw a Norville damn up in
California you always have to be
prepared for emergencies done in
California there are those of us like me
who have not been prepared
for emergencies we've spent our time
talking about how the big earthquake is
coming then we have no actual
preparations for earthquakes that is why
you need my Patriot supplies you get a
four-week emergency food supply for 99
bucks which is all a lot of food or just
ninety nine dollars make sure that you
and your family are safe and fed you
order now at 888 803 1413 so 8 8 8 8 03
14 13 or online at prepare with been
calm prepare with been calm so you can
be down in that bunker with my podcast
and your food in case things go
dramatically wrong breakfast lunch and
dinner for 28 days 99 bucks honestly
it's a real good price for that much
food and to make sure that you only have
to buy it once and then you're solid
right I mean then you're good stays
fresh up to 25 years you don't have to
worry about this following apart we're
actually going to do a taste test in the
office because apparently the food is
really good so we're going to we're
going to have people actually taste test
it in the office and we'll let you know
how that goes it's a 99 bucks plus free
shipping limit two per caller so you
can't file like a thousand of them in
case you plan to spend the next 50 years
in a bunker no okay 888 803 1413 prepare
with been calm prepare with been calm
8880 3 14 13 from my Patriot supply you
always want to be prepared for emergency
whether or not it happens what's the
worst that happened you took 99 bucks
and I are prepared for a tornado an
earthquake or a financial collapse or or
Barack Obama rushing in on his white
steed to take back over the country I
mean so in any case that's that's
worthwhile doing against prepare with
Ben dot-com a final note about the media
especially that immigration they're
really making it seem like crisis point
like Trump is going out there knocking
down doors for adding people out of
their houses I mean I seem to remember
when bill clinton literally knocked down
doors literally had to swat teams knock
down doors to drag a kid away from his
family and back to Cuba and the media
didn't make a huge deal as huge deal out
of that isn't making out of this it was
a big deal but it wasn't as big a deal
as what they're doing now here's a story
that's being promoted all over the media
a child and an anti-trump protests
talking to MSNBC talking about how his
father and and how the father and uncle
were deported and actually we've been
walking with these martyrs for a while
now we were surprised to see that some
of the littlest ones are leading this
Valley people like Jose right over here
but they tell me why why were you
leading the March just now because i
hate Trump and and so they're my parents
and other friends and he deported my
father and my uncle because they were
illegal immigrants thank you so much for
saying so the immigration is very near
and dear random child who can now tell
us a sob story okay we don't know anyone
is father in his uncle we don't you
notice that we don't know anything did
she ask like so did they have criminal
records I don't know who they deported
right you know that the Trump
administration so far has been focusing
on people with prior history of
criminality so I assume that you know
he's not just going round up illegal
immigrant I live in Los Angeles okay Los
Angeles is like the number one city in
America for illegal immigration and I
haven't seen the ice vans on the street
going and rounding people up at home
depot it ain't happening so this idea
that there's this vast crackdown on
illegal immigration it's just not true
but now we're getting stories about
women taking sanctuary in churches to
avoid Donald Trump evil deportation
squads Genesis a Quaker reading houses
they call it where they have taken then
a woman from Peru and our two young
children who were born in the US because
they say they don't want to see families
split apart not beyond the door does
Ingrid inca la jolla torrey feels safe
what will happen if you go back to Peru
I you know I have two children here they
go to school and I don't think I don't
want to go back here in the Mountain
View Quaker meeting house she and her
two children had been living for the
past three months the assumption is
immigration agents would not come and
get her in a church we don't expect that
I would revile eight that things were
here she came here from Peru 17 years
ago to visit a relative and didn't leave
she was convicted of a felony for using
a false social security number and has
been ordered to be deported Yolo neko
case's that is pretty much why Jeanette
mascara a mother of four took sanctuary
in the Unitarian Church in a jean all
these people taking sanctuary in
churches it's something out of
back of Notre Dahmer and Quasimodo
swings down on his rope grabs Esmeralda
and there they are up in the tower of
shouting sanctuary okay so do we need a
better comprehensive immigration policy
yeah we do we do okay I've been in
advocate for a long time of the idea
that we close the border and then we go
through the legal immigrants who are
here and we figure out who deserves
sustained who deserves to go I don't
think that we ought to treat people as a
class exactly I don't think that just
because you came in the country legally
everybody who came in the country
illegally is exactly the same I don't
think that's right I think that's
actually kind of silly that said the
media coverage of this makes it seem
like if you watch this you would think
that the Trump Gestapo is going door to
door knocking down doors and grabbing
people out of their houses I mean how
can you watch that not feel anxious this
is why the left is anxious and that's
not going to be good that's not going to
be good now we're going to have to
continue talking about it on the other
side of the break over at daily wire.com
there's a lot more to come out and talk
about how Trump is responding to all of
this and whether it's ratcheting down to
ratcheting up tensions over daily wire
calm become a subscriber for eight
dollars a month go and check it out over
there and if you become an annual
subscriber right now then you get a free
copy of the arroyo fictional film about
what's happening down southern border
where the Shapiro store which is coming
I think next month and that will have
all sorts of gear you'll get all sorts
of discount on that stuff we have books
that are coming out all sorts of
wonderful things of you become a
subscriber right now at daily wired.com
so check that out also later you can
listen to us at iTunes or SoundCloud if
you do go and raid us at the iTunes
Store but we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile the media